yeah you are when you throw that on the
floor you're litter in the city in a
minute I'm going to litter the floor
with you we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no good news so here's
something positive that happened why'
you rip it off why' you rip it off why'
you rip it off put it back why' you rip
it off put it back what show me what
you're holding so yeah keep it on no
what are you doing you know where they
are right now do you have any idea where
they are right
now all right I'm a veteran I'm telling
you I'm not Jewish he's not Jewish I
don't know if he is or not doesn't
matter this is in the US New York City
you don't have a right to touch that
this a free country you can wave
your Palestine flag and say death to the
Jews or America whatever you want but we
can put up sign okay then don't rip that
down you are doing something you're
offending us
mother yeah you are when you throw that
on the floor you're liter in the city in
a minute I'm going to lit the floor with
you you have so move the on do you have
proof they're not kidnapped no so shut
the
up I know that's what you want D you in
the hospital
[Music]
pie